I was in high security in federal prison
and was detained and I was in what they
call the hole I had a special phone
restriction that I was only allowed to
call like five people you're hacking
from prison hacking from prison let me
tell you how is whenever I had to make a
phone call they would actually shackle
my room shackle my legs they'd walk me
like 30 feet to this room that had a
bank of pay phones the guard would look
at you know the numbers I could call you
say which number do you want me back so
I'd walk back and forth when I was
talking and I would constantly be
scratching my back and I just you know
keep talking I'd be rubbing my back and
then behind my back I would just hang up
you know hang you know push down the
switch hook and then I'd move my hand to
the front because I knew that I had 18
seconds before the phone went into
reorder meaning BBB so I had 18 seconds
to do this so I just continued to
scratch and then I put my hand behind
again and dial zero plus the number I
wanted